[Music]
foreign
so in the last lecture we derived this
simplest first order linear differential
equation for things like the population
growth of a population of bunnies or how
much your loan grows if you have
compound interest
radioactive decay of a radioactive
element or isotope or the thermal
runaway in a little you know piece of
electronics so x dot equals axis means
the derivative of x with respect to time
is linearly proportional to x with a
proportionality constant a a is just a
number and we wrote down that the
solution of this is
uh X at time t
is e to the a t times my initial
condition which I'm going to say is X at
time 0 x naught so sometimes we use
shorthand X subscript 0 means my initial
condition X at Time Zero okay so we
derived this last time and so this time
what I'm going to do is I'm actually
going to solve this differential
equation using a power series or a
Taylor series expansion for X of T and
we're actually going to derive this
exponential function from scratch this
is a very powerful method in ordinary
differential equations you can actually
use this approach to solve much much
nastier differential equations things
like um where you would get the solution
being vessels functions or Aries
functions differential equations that
are non-linear you can solve using the
technique I'm about to show you okay
so again we asked ourselves this
question uh kind of what is what
is this e to the a t and so I'm going to
kind of derive it from scratch today
using a power series or a Taylor series
expansion so essentially what we're
going to do
is we're going to assume that we can
expand X of t
in terms of powers of T so we're going
to say that this is equal to some
constant C naught plus some constant C1
times t plus c 2 t squared
plus c 3 T cubed and I think I'm going
to go up to C
4 t to the fourth plus dot dot dot and
we're going to assume that this
expansion goes on forever that this is
you know some some essentially some
polynomial Taylor series expansion of
the solution X of t
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take this expansion we're going
to take its derivative x dot and we're
also going to multiply it with a and
we're going to set those two expressions
equal to each other and solve for what
all these coefficients have to equal to
satisfy this differential equation okay
so I'm just going to write this out we
also have that um
uh I don't want to write this I want to
say like x dot
which of course we know is just D DT of
X the derivative of this with respect to
time so x dot if I take x dot then my C
naught is going to go to zero and get
canceled and so I'm going to get just a
C1
plus 2
c 2 times T again if I take the
derivative of a constant t squared it's
2 times that constant times t two times
that constant times t plus 3 c 3 t
squared plus
4 C 4 T cubed plus
um
dot dot
good that's all I'm going to need for
now and then the last thing I'm going to
do so now I have my x dot I have my X
and now I'm just going to multiply X by
a x by a and I'm going to write down you
know a x of T equals it's this first
expression times a so it's a c naught
plus a c 1 t plus a C2 t squared plus a
c 3 T cubed plus a c 4 T 4 plus dot dot
dot and again each of these goes on
forever this is a an infinite expansion
in polynomials
um
if you're watching this online which you
obviously are
um there is a whole lecture on what is a
Taylor series what is this infinite
polynomial expansion of my function uh X
of T you know how do we plot this in
Matlab and Python and really understand
why is it that I can approximate these
functions using infinite uh series or
polynomials in the independent variable
so you can click on that if you're you
know confused or need a refresher but
now what we're going to do is we're
literally going to take
this expression for um for x dot and
this expression for ax and we're just
going to set them equal to each other
because we know that our differential
equation is essentially a rule saying x
dot has to equal a times x at every
instant in time for every t x dot has to
equal a times x
and what it means for this to be true at
every instance in time is that it means
that every single term in this expansion
has to equal each other so the the T to
the zero term these have to equal each
other the T to the ones term these have
to equal each other so essentially
locally Point wise these have to equal
each other these have to equal each
other these have to equal each other and
so on and so forth and you can kind of
convince yourself that the only way for
this to be true at every instant in time
is for these to equal each other for
every Power of T this is actually a
really good exercise to get comfortable
uh with these series is think about you
know if this is true for T equals zero
and one and two and three in all time
you know 1.1 1.2 1.3 for all time
the only way that can be true for all
time is that if every single term in
these expansions of x dot and ax equal
each other
and so that's kind of cool so
essentially what that allows us to do is
essentially solve x dot equals a x we're
going to match
each
power
of t
in each of these expressions
and so essentially what that's going to
look like is the maybe I'll make sure I
have some place to stand so what that's
going to look like is the T to the zero
power or the the ones placed here
essentially says you know this is equal
to one
that essentially says that a times C
naught has to equal C1 so uh C1 equals a
times a
times C naught
um
one little caveat here one little thing
I know
that
X at times zero
if I plug in times 0 for all of these
times x at times 0 has to equal C naught
uh C naught because basically at Time
Zero all of these terms go to zero
except for C naught so C naught has to
be my initial condition x x naught okay
so this means
um that this equals
a
times x naught
good
so
so we know that c naught equals x naught
we know that C1 equals a times
C1 equals a times C naught so that
equals a times x naught now we're going
to match the T to the first Power okay
so t to the ones power
says
2c2
has to equal
a times C1
and this is pretty easy to solve for C2
again we're just solving for C1 C2 C3 C4
and then we're going to plug those back
in and see what expression we get
so this implies that C2
equals a over 2 c 1
which equals a squared over 2
X not see what I did there so this is
essentially what's known as a recursion
or recursive relationship is that every
um
C2 was a function of C1 but C1 was a
function of c0 which was in turn a
function of X naught so all of these are
kind of recursively building on the last
power to figure out what C2 equals in
terms of C1 and what C3 equals in terms
of C2 so I'll just do a couple more of
these so the t2's power again these have
to equal each other that says 3 times C2
equals a times C2
I'm running out of space here that
implies that C2
sorry
you should catch me yelling into your
screen when I mess up uh
uh this was a C3 3 times C3
and so C3
po C3
equals a over 3 C 2.
and C2 is this so This equals
a cubed over three times two
I'm going to call that 3 factorial
times x naught
and I'm just going to do one more of
these so you really see the pattern why
I wrote a factorial instead of just 3
times 2 I'm going to do the the T
3 power the T3 power matching those says
that 4
C4 equals a C3
that implies
that C4 equals a fourths C3 which is
a to the fourth divided by four times
three factorial which is
4 factorial
times x naught and so I can write this
down in general dot dot dot I'm just
going to write like you know t to the
nth power the the nth power of T is
going to be
uh n plus one
c n plus one
equals a times c n
and recursively that's going to imply
that c n plus 1 equals a over
n plus 1 c n which is going to equal a
to the power n plus 1 over n plus 1
factorial times x naught so kind of
every single term in this Taylor series
expansion of x dot and ax have to equal
each other for this to be true at all
time
and so that gives me equations for C1 as
a function of C naught right C1 has to
equal a times C naught C2 2 times C2 has
to equal a times C1
3 times c 3 has to equal a times C2 and
so on and so forth
and because I know that c naught is my
initial condition because if I plug in t
0 here I get x 0 equals c naught I can
set up this recursion relationship and
write down all of these constants as a
function of X naught okay so I'm just
going to actually like Circle these this
one
this one
this one so all of these expressions for
um
all of these constants are Written In
terms just of a and X naught and now I
can collect all of those terms and
replace all of these constants here for
X of T so that's my last step and then
we're done okay maybe I'll use orange
because I think orange looks really cool
so now what we have is X of t
equals
everything has an X naught so I'm
actually going to pull that X naught out
I'm just going to say x naught
times
times x of T equals right all of these
constants have a some combination of A's
times x naught so I'm just going to pull
that out so C naught is a
maybe maybe I'm not going to pull them
out I think this will be too confusing
I'm just going to write the whole thing
and then we'll simplify okay so
um
I'm not going to skip steps in my Taylor
series
so X of T is C naught that's
a x naught
Plus
c1t which is
ah sorry I'm dying here
all right bear with me
going too fast I'm going to slow down X
of T is C naught plus C1 t plus C2 t
squared and so on and so forth C naught
is just X naught so this is first off
just X naught
and then C1 is a times x naught so
that's uh
just going to say x naught
a times t
2 times t squared is this this guy so
that's Plus
X naught
a squared t squared over 2. a squared t
squared over 2.
the T cubed term is C3 which again is
this is X naught
times
a cubed T cubed over 3 factorial
a cubed T cubed over 3 factorial
plus I'm just going to write down X
naught a to the fourth t to the fourth
over 4 factorial plus dot dot dot dot
and I'm even going to write this down
it's plus X naught you know a to the n t
to the N Over N factorial plus dot dot
dot forever and ever and ever
and so here if I pull out my X naught
what I get now
is that this is you know X naught times
one
plus a t
plus a squared t squared over 2
factorial is just 2.
plus a cubed T cubed over 3 factorial
plus you know a 4 T 4 over 4 factorial
plus dot dot dot dot forever
this is literally the definition of e to
the a t this here this is actually how
we would Define e to the a t is by this
power series expansion here so so what
we've done
is we've written down our differential
equation we've derived this you know in
the previous lecture we assumed that X
of T has some power series expansion and
then we have figured out what all of
those coefficients had to be to satisfy
this equation we literally computed x
dot the power series a times x the power
series we set them equal to each other
term by term by term
and we got this expression for what x of
T is purely as a function of of a and t
and
it could be that you would just you know
write down this power series and say hmm
I see this differential equation all the
time I'm going to give this a name this
is going to be my special function you
know Steve's function of a t and you
know that's kind of what Euler did right
so Euler get it's a lot of credit for
writing down this exponential function
this you know this is Euler's number e
which is the solution of this most
common differential equation
so you can solve these differential
equations using power series and this
technique is very very general you can
use this for much more complicated Odes
that are non-linear really hairy systems
this is how you would derive vessels
functions this is how you would derive
Aries functions lots of
things you can solve when you know that
you can write down a power series and
plug it into your differential equation
okay and in fact this is what the
exponential function is this is the
power series expansion for e to the a t
Okay so that's that's kind of a neat
connection okay again if you want a
little recap or refresher on you know
how you can approximate functions with
these infinite series of polynomials uh
check out the the video on you know
Taylor series and power series all right
thank you
foreign
[Music]